with this in mind  here our incubator will focus on  five main priorities first of all it's  the sequencing  to identify variants quicker second if  necessary  science has to adapt the existing  vaccines so we have to focus  on the research third point  we need well-organized clinical trials  and that is why we are launching today a  european  clinical trials network  fourth point we need to enable emma to  fast track the regulatory approval  of updated vaccines and manufacturing  sites  and fifth and finally we need to  further upscale mass production of new  vaccines but also of existing vaccines  the here is  the pandemic has shown us three things  we have to act early  we have to invest at large scale we have  to partner up  this is why we are proposing hera  incubator now  and this is the message i will take to  the next week's meeting  with the heads of state and government  the eu leaders  you